>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: I'm
Carolyn Rapkievian and we're here
at the Library of Congress today.
We've been enjoying the music of
Zulal and Ara Dinkjian and I'd
like each of them to
introduce themselves.
>> Teni Apelian: I am part of
Zulal, the Armenian a cappella trio.
My name is Teni.
>> Yeraz Markarian: I'm
Yeraz, also from Zulal.
>> Anais Tekerian: And I'm Anais.
>> Ara Dinkjian: I'm Ara Dinkjian.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: So
I'm going to ask all of you,
what are your earliest
memories of singing or playing
or even hearing Armenia music?
Who wants to go first?
>> Yeraz Markarian: I
don't remember a time
when I didn't listen
to Armenian music.
I feel like it was
playing in the car,
playing in the home,
from when I was born.
I don't remember a
time when it started.
I feel like it was always there.
It was part of parties and we
heard opera and we heard classical
and we heard all different
versions of it,
but I don't remember
a time when it began.
I feel like it was always there.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: When
did you start singing it?
>> Yeraz Markarian: I think
I started singing when I was
about six or seven years old.
And I stole some tapes from my
dad's library and I willed myself
to learn these songs the way
the singers were singing them.
And I feel like I burned
through these tapes to the point
where my parents were just listening
to the songs over and over again
and I think I started
around that age.
Yeah.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian:
Anais, what about you?
>> Anais Tekerian: I think it was
-- I'm no longer religious now,
but as a child because
of my grandmother I went
to Armenian church and because I
had a sweet little voice they put me
in the choir and so I started
singing there, and from the age
of 11 until I went off to college.
So it was mostly liturgical.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: And Teni?
>> Teni Apelian: Mine
was a mix of everything.
We went to church every Sunday so,
you know, at that time it wasn't
like now I have a sort of a
light version for my kids,
but when I was a kid it was
a full two hour commitment
and I remember really
attaching myself to the melodies
and the rituals and all
of those things combined.
The folk music probably came a
little bit later or in school
and I don't really have a precise
moment that it started, but yeah.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: And Ara?
>> Ara Dinkjian: Yeah.
For me the most obvious
answer is the fact
that my father is Onnik Dinkjian, a
very renowned Armenian folk singer,
but beyond that, like the
ladies said, Armenian music was
in the house in that
-- We went to church.
So there's the liturgical music.
My parents sang in the choir.
I eventually became the organist.
All their social activities revolved
around choruses and dance groups
and so there were rehearsals and
there were concerts constantly.
And when they socialized,
when people came over,
they just spontaneously
started to sing in the house.
So just like the ladies
said, there was never a time
when music was not in the house.
That's how we all grew up.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: Ara, you
were saying that your family was
from Dikranagerd on your
father's side and [inaudible]
on your mother's side,
and each of you --
I haven't had a chance to ask you
where your families
were from originally.
Do you know?
>> Anais Tekerian: Well, my -- I'm
Armenian on my dad's side and I know
that my grandmother's
family is from [inaudible].
>> Yeraz Markarian: And I'm also
half Dikranagerdzi on my mom's side
and on my father's
side I'm [Vanadzi?].
>> Teni Apelian: My mom's
father was from [inaudible]
and on my dad's side it's
[inaudible] and [inaudible].
So a mix.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian:
So I wondered --
I know in one of the songs that you
sing you sing in different dialects.
How did you come to do that,
and how did you research that?
>> Teni Apelian: Well, we were
speaking with Ara earlier about,
you know, the beauty of
music of the Caucasus,
and how different cultures have
informed each other's music,
but what's happened even
within Armenian folk is
because the melodies were passed on
orally they usually weren't written,
especially in the villages.
Ideas and melodies ended up shifting
a little every time it traveled,
every time it went
to a different place.
So this was lucky.
I mean we listen to a
lot of archival songs.
So this happened to reveal itself
to us which was a little bit of luck
and a little bit of collecting
of which Ara is much more the
collector, but it happened to be
that we found these three
different archival melodies
and then the fourth one which was
a [speaking foreign language].
It was, right?
Yes. It was.
So we ended up doing feeling
the need to pair these melodies,
and we ended up through
that research finding the
different regions and figuring
out the different dialects
and putting it together.
>> Ara Dinkjian: I
think the question
of dialects is a very important
one because many of them,
if not most of them, are on
the verge of being extinct.
In particular, for example, there
has not been an Armenian born
in Dikranagerd in over 50 years.
And the absolutely unique
dialect of Dikranagerdzi Armenian,
when it's spoken in its purest form,
those of us who understand
Armenian will not understand it.
So the fact that when the generation
that knows it, and they are now
in their eighties and
nineties -- When they are gone,
that dialect will cease to exist.
This is obviously a result
of events from 100 years ago,
but it's also a product
of the technology,
how the world has gotten smaller
and you're not just confined
to your one area and
your one way of speaking.
So this is all just part of the
transitions in life, I guess.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: Ara, you're
a collector of old recordings.
How have these inspired your work?
>> Ara Dinkjian: One of the
reasons that I collect music is
because when I'm learning
something I want it to be --
at least the foundation of it,
to be as accurate as possible.
Not that I want to copy it as if
I'm some kind of a museum piece,
but before you learn to
interpret something you should try
to learn the origins of it.
And, frankly, the earliest sonic
evidence we have of our music is
in -- If they're not on cylinders,
then they are on the
flat 78 RPM records.
And so I -- Since I was a young kid
I've been fanatically collecting
them because there
might be a fourth verse
that simply people
don't know anymore
or there may be an
instrumental introduction
to a piece that we simply don't do.
Well, they're preserved there.
And to me these are
cultural treasures.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian:
Do you incorporate
that in to your music sometimes?
>> Ara Dinkjian: I absolutely do.
If I'm performing a piece that has
existed for, let's say, 100 years,
I go back to those recordings.
Again not to try to copy
them, but to be aware of them
and in some cases,
yes, incorporate them.
As far as my own personal music
is concerned, my own compositions,
all of that has deeply
influenced what I do.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: And you
also mentioned your father.
Talk a little bit more about how he
has influenced your musical style.
>> Ara Dinkjian: Well, I learned the
folk music and the classical music
from the fact that back when I was
a kid you didn't use babysitters.
If there was chorus rehearsal,
you'd take the kids with you.
And there was every week.
So I wound up bored out of my mind
because I want to play with a toy
or something and I have
to wait for two hours
for this rehearsal to be over.
But without realizing it I learned
all of this great repertoire
and also I would sit with my
mother in the sopranos, you know,
and learn that part, and then I'd
go sit with my father in the tenors
and I'm learning that part.
But again kind of not realizing
what a rich treasure this was.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: Some
of your work is original
work too, a lot of your work.
How do you go about creating
your original pieces?
>> Ara Dinkjian: I don't like
to think of myself as a creator.
I think that's very pompous.
And I've found this phrase that
more accurately describes how I feel
about that creative process which is
that I describe myself
as a song finder.
And what I mean by that is the
best songs come fully formed
and you just hear them.
You don't have to fix them
or add to them or edit them.
And if that's true, then it means
they already exist somewhere.
So I feel like, wow, I
found this beautiful song.
So that's how it comes to me and
sometimes it's in the shower,
sometimes it's in a dream.
My wife even knows sometimes I
wake up in the middle of the night,
turn a light on, and she doesn't
anymore say, "What are you doing?"
Because she knows he hears
something and he's writing it down
and then going back to sleep.
So I don't want to take
too much credit for it,
but I'm lucky that
I hear it sometimes.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: How
do you find the material
and how do you choose the
material that you decide to sing?
>> Yeraz Markarian:
It's so complicated.
I think we -- Similar to what Ara's
talking about, we hear something
in a song that speaks to us.
And the songs that we
choose are really the ones
that touch us in some way.
We sing these songs
because we have to.
We know that there's no choice.
We -- They're coming through us.
We're holding on to them
the best that we can.
But they're sort of speaking
to us through history.
A lot of times we hear an
old archival recording.
A lot of times we -- Sometimes
we might hear another performance
by another artist of an old folk
song and there's something about it
that speaks to us in some way.
>> Teni Apelian: I mean for
us I feel like many things are
about the balance of three.
So it's not only the vocal
blend, but it's also, you know,
our different approach maybe to
a harmony or what comes from --
What's, I think, interesting about
our group is that any one of us
by ourselves are not anywhere
near what we are together.
And a lot of our song choices end
up being revealed in that process
because although we may be very
different, and we may have sort
of a different idea of things,
when it comes to music all three
of us will very clearly be
able to define what we --
what is evocative and
what speaks to us.
So I feel like the music
cuts through very clearly
and when there's a song that
maybe two of us like and one
of us doesn't, then
that means something.
So we end up doing the things
that speak to us across the trio
and those end up being the
ones that we're meant to do.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: And how do
you work out your arrangements?
How does that happen?
>> Teni Apelian: Very collectively.
Yeah. Very much a process
that we do together.
>> Yeraz Markarian:
It's a little bit
like birthing a child
as well, you know.
We go through some trials
and tribulation sometimes.
Sometimes things come
very easily and quickly.
Each song has its own spirit,
in a way, and we follow it.
>> Anais Tekerian: Some songs want
us to sing them and some don't.
>> Yeraz Markarian: Yeah.
Those -- There will be a song maybe
that collectively we
each individually love,
and yet when we try to sing it
together something doesn't happen
and we're sad and we
have to let that go.
That song wasn't meant for
us for whatever reason.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: How has
your music or your thinking
about music evolved over the years?
>> Ara Dinkjian: When I
was younger I wanted to --
I'm a little embarrassed to say it.
I wanted to show what I
know or what I can do.
And I no longer feel that need now.
I want to hit one note and have
people say, "Oh, I love the oud."
Not necessarily, "I love
the way he plays the oud."
But, "Oh, I love the
that instrument."
And ultimately I'm looking for that
perfect song which will be one note
and people are going to say, "Yeah.
He found it.
He finally found it."
So short answer might -- I think
my music is becoming simpler.
>> Teni Apelian: I don't know.
I mean our music is -- Like anyone's
music, right, is an extension
of themselves, their
spirit, their relationship
with each other, and themselves.
So for us, you know, within this
trio, we've grown into women.
We were girls when we started and
for us Zulal has been very much,
you know, the -- There's the music
and then there's like
our relationship.
And I think the music
is very much --
The evolution of the
music is a representation
of our journey together.
We started when we were
younger and now we've gone
through many evolutions personally
within that time together
and the music, if anything,
is a reflection of that.
>> Ara Dinkjian: Can
I ask a question?
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: Absolutely.
I was about to say -- Yes.
>> Ara Dinkjian: Has
motherhood affected your music?
>> Anais Tekerian: Of course.
How could it not?
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: In what way?
>> Ara Dinkjian: Thank you.
>> Anais Tekerian: Well, I
know just as an artist I know
that I have developed a lot
since becoming a mother.
I feel like when I went back on
stage after becoming a mother
and living through grief before that
and so forth things have opened.
So, it's a little bit perverse,
but things have opened up in a way
that I had to work at before that.
And I think that comes out in
the voice too since, you know --
for any musician or artist
it comes out in the work.
But there's an openness
and there's both a strength
and an extra vulnerability
that I don't think you necessarily
have before experiencing a lot
of life's big experiences.
>> Teni Apelian: Motherhood
has also made me,
and I'm sure for you guys it's
the same, more grateful to be able
to do this when you have
given so much to your children
and it's -- you've experienced that.
To be able to come and really
sit inside this music and be able
to share it with other
people, there's a new a feeling
of gratitude to be able to do that.
>> Yeraz Markarian: And I think
there's something about it
that makes me want
to work harder at it.
I'm giving up a lot.
I'm leaving a lot at
home, as we all are,
to be here and to be doing this.
And so we want to make
it count every time.
We want to make every song hit
somebody in the heart or feel right
for somebody or touch
somebody in some way.
We want to communicate what
we're holding from our ancestors
and to be able to relay that
to someone somewhere sitting
in the room and for
them to feel that.
And we want to be able
to do that every time
because we're giving
up a lot to be here.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian:
What about fatherhood?
>> Ara Dinkjian: Fatherhood
inspired me to write lullabies
for my children and to think
about what I'm leaving them
when I'm no longer here.
And the older you get the more
you realize time is so precious
so you have to do things.
You have to do them now.
If there's things you want to
accomplish, don't procrastinate.
It will never be ready.
It will never be perfect.
You have to do it now because
when you're gone that's what
you're leaving.
So yeah. Fatherhood
changed everything for me.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: Is there
anything else in particular
that really changed what you do?
Parenthood obviously.
>> Ara Dinkjian: I think every
event in our lives affects us.
I mean as a composer, you know, I've
always kind of lamented the fact
that music used to be for a purpose.
And what I mean by that is there
was the song that you would sing
to ask God to make it rain so that
you can eat or there was the song
that you sang when somebody died
or there was the song that you sang
to put your baby to sleep.
We've kind of lost
that in our society.
Music has become something
that you're on the stage,
you're physically separated
from your audience,
they're doing something up there,
and then when they're
done you express,
you know, yourself by clapping.
And then they go back stage and --
That's not what music used to be.
As a matter of fact,
in some cultures there's
not even a word for music.
It's just what they do
when they're hunting.
They sing these things.
And I kind of lament the
fact that we've lost that.
So I try to get that back
in my own personal way,
writing songs for a reason.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: You know,
you're all very accomplished
musicians and I want
to ask you why you have
chosen to focus on folk music,
Armenian folk music, as what you do.
>> Yeraz Markarian:
We tried other genres.
Didn't we?
From the very beginning --
We've been doing this over 10
years now together, and we tried.
We experimented with different
styles of music, if I remember,
and it was something -- When I
said that we sing these songs
because we have to, there is
something about the folk music
and just imagining that, as
Ara said, people created music
for a purpose and also
to express themselves
and to express what
was happening for them
in that moment whether it was
grief, whether it was joy,
whether it was struggle
or hardship or love
or yearning, whatever it was.
They used music and song
and voice to express that.
And so there was something
about that quality
of communicating what was happening
for you internally in your soul
and to be able to share that with
somebody, there was something
about that, that spoke to us.
And we couldn't do anything else.
I don't know that it was a choice.
>> Anais Tekerian: Also for us
there's something very unifying
about it because we settled
on Armenian folk music
for reasons being all of, at least
part, Armeinan extraction and --
But we're all very
different aesthetics.
Different aesthetics in general.
Visual and even in terms
of what we like to listen
to outside of Armenian music.
But somehow we came together and
we melded our different styles
in to this thing that works and we
created our own little thing that --
It just -- It works for us
and somehow Armenian folk
was the unifying element
for the three of us.
>> Ara Dinkjian: For myself, I would
never impose what I'm about to say
on anybody else, but for me the
brain is the great enemy of music.
And what I mean by that is
music touches me the most
when I'm not conscious of it,
when it's touching my heart
as opposed to stimulating my brain.
And so if that's true, I can
tell you that I responded even
as a little boy -- I physically
and emotionally responded
to Armenian folk music without
understanding why or anything.
Now I want to give you
a specific example.
I always found myself gravitating
towards these folk songs
in the 10/8 time signature.
And it wasn't until
I was in my twenties
that I made the connection that,
wait a minute, my ancestors are
from Dikranagerd and [inaudible]
and 10/8 is the beat there.
And I know that that
is not a coincidence,
that it is I'm carrying the
genetic blood of my ancestors.
And instead of intellectualizing
it, my body and soul just responded
to it and it confirms that you
need to trust your heart even
if you don't understand why
you think that girl is pretty
or why you don't like
that food or whatever.
You need to trust what your body
and soul is telling you because all
of that history is inside of you.
And so that's what I trust.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: I
want to ask all of you also,
is there something else
that you would like to talk
about that I haven't asked you?
>> Ara Dinkjian: Well, I'm
never at a loss for words.
I'm sorry.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: Go for it.
>> Ara Dinkjian: I want to mention
that we had a rehearsal last week
and I told the girls that not only
of course I admire what they do
and I like what they do, but
I wanted them to understand
that they can't minimize
their accomplishments
because they don't know
who they're reaching
and what effect that's having.
Their CDs can be copied and
travel all around the world
and somebody somewhere is listening
and it's changing somebody's life.
So that's not to say that
they should have a big head,
but it was my way of telling them
that they are influencing younger
generations by doing something
that is firmly rooted in
their history and yet is fresh
and contemporary and very positive.
And I think that's a great service
that they're giving back
to their great history.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian:
Ara, talk about playing
in Turkey on April 24th this year.
>> Ara Dinkjian: It was a decision
that actually came quite easy for me
because to go to the land where
the atrocities were held I think
in some ways is more
powerful than, you know --
In America we are geographically
and therefore emotionally
kind of isolated.
There's something going on
over there across the ocean.
There's some -- We don't know.
We don't feel it.
We don't even understand it.
But to be there was
of course emotional,
but I think most importantly
there are Turks, Kurds,
and of course Armenians that know
the history and that are anxious
to reveal what they know.
And in many cases to great danger
for themselves, for their lives.
Not us here in America, but for
them because they live there
because they know that the truth,
while it is at times very painful
and ugly, it's really our only hope.
And for me it would
be unconscionable not
to support the risk that
they're taking to say, "Yes.
There was a genocide.
And we need to face that and
then we need to move forward."
I needed to go there
and support those
who are putting their own
lives at risk for our cause.
I say our cause, but the very fact
that they're doing it means they
understand it's not an Armenian
Turkish issue.
It is a humanity issue that
in some cases, for example,
the Kurds are now living
through all over.
And so it was vital to be there
and emotional beyond words.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: And you
were playing with other musicians
of different backgrounds.
Is that --
>> Ara Dinkjian: Absolutely.
There were -- Everybody was
represented on the stage.
And that's what it's got to be.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: Tell me a
little bit more about that concert.
>> Ara Dinkjian: Well, the
concert was in Istanbul
and it was a four hour
concert and it was attended
by I think over 5,000 people.
It was broadcast live
throughout the world.
And there were I don't know, maybe
over 100 different artists, singers.
And everybody was represented.
When I say everybody, Armenians,
of course, but also Turks and Kurds
and -- as well as Europeans and
everybody kind of uniting to say
that again it's not a
Turkish Armenian issue.
It's a human issue
that we need to resolve
so that we can prevent
it from happening again.
And everybody was -- really
put their egos to the side
and performed from their heart.
And I know I was very
proud to be part of that.
And I hope -- I hope that world
was watching because sometimes
who history teaches you
is your enemy if you get
to know them they might
not be your enemy.
They might actually want
to be working with you.
And I think it's very important
to keep those doors open
because actually you
can accomplish more
that way than remaining isolated.
And that concert was I think
a perfect example of that.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian:
And it was recorded?
>> Ara Dinkjian: It was recorded.
Actually you could go on YouTube and
watch the whole four hour concert.
Yes. And the concert
is called In Memorium.
So I think you can YouTube that
and watch the whole concert.
And there's an array of stars
again from around the world.
And so many different
languages were represented.
But all for that united
message that we have to somehow
as a species prevent these
things from happening again.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: You
know, our music crosses borders
and in many ways historically just
because we were at a crossroads
of cultures and because
of our recent history maybe you
could talk a little bit more
about influences back and forth and
in your music or in the folk music.
>> Teni Apelian: It's best done
looking at a piece of music
across different cultures.
[Inaudible] is one.
[Inaudible] which you have in
Iran there's a Turkish version.
There's a [inaudible] version.
There's an Armenian version.
I mean I feel like in a way the
music is the clearest example
of this idea is -- I
mean we were speaking
about this earlier backstage.
>> Ara Dinkjian: Yes.
You can take a melody and then
you can have 10 different cultures
arguing as to, you know, what
is the origin of this melody.
And it's -- It can get serious,
but in the end it's --
It can get silly also.
Really I think for us to be an
Armenian is just to have a sense
of your history and what your
obligation towards that history
in to the future is all about.
If you ask about specifically
influences, you know, in our music,
just speaking on behalf of
myself, the mere fact that I'm born
in America, well, that
changes everything.
And just to get a little
specific, I hope it's not boring,
you know Armenian folk music does
not employ harmony traditionally.
And it employs microtone, microtonal
modes, etcetera, etcetera.
Harmony is a Western
European concept.
So my life's work is how do I
wed the microtonal ancient modes
with western harmony, because I'm
born in America, I can't ignore
that part of who I am
-- I'm an American.
How do I wed those in a way
that neither is offended
and both are elevated?
It's a challenge and it's a
challenge that is my life's work
and it's -- I treasure
trying to accomplish that.
In some cases it succeeds.
In some cases it doesn't.
But then we have the Zulal trio who
are singing Armenian folk melodies
with rich deep harmonies.
And the interesting thing, if
you don't mind me saying this,
is that especially with Komitas, he
established and defined and declared
that there is a unique thing called
Armenian harmony which is different
than Georgian or [inaudible] or
Western European or what have you.
And the girls are a great
example of helping to define that.
>> Yeraz Markarian: Just this idea
of being in America and all three
of us sang a cappella in ensemble
form in college and yet Anais was
in Slavic a cappella
choir, I was in a sort
of modern pop a cappella group,
and Teni was in a jazz
a cappella ensemble.
And so just even our
own musical upbringings
and of course more
diverse than just that --
But just even coming from
a harmony point of view,
it also brings in all
of those pieces.
Again, you know, we were born
and raised here, all three of us,
and we're reaching back through
time to try to elevate or connect
with this music in a way and be
true to who we are at the same time.
So I think that everything
that I sing I agree with.
>> Teni Apelian: I just want to
add one more thing to this idea
of music across cultures.
So we got an email a couple of days
ago, I don't know if you saw it,
from a guy in Turkey
who said, "Your music --
" It was in kind of funky English
and it said, "Your music touches me
or makes me feel something the same
way our Turkish folk music does."
In the same way.
And he said, you know,
"You're welcome here.
I personally welcome you to come."
But in a way it touches
back to what Ara was saying
about trying to find simplicity.
And I think what, you know -- The
truth behind this music moving
across peoples and cultures is
that when it's right it touches
the most simple parts of us
that are the same across
countries and ethnicities.
And so real folk music I
think really is borderless
because it evokes something that
-- in the part of us that is human.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: So
what are you all thinking
about for the future now beyond
getting simpler and simpler?
[laughter]
>> Teni Apelian: To be the
John Cage of folk music.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian:
Until there's nothing left.
>> Yeraz Markarian: Well, we're
working on our third album
which will be titled
"Seven Springs."
And we're close to wrapping it up.
We have finished off a bunch
of songs and we're just sort
of recording the last few pieces.
So it should be out soon.
That's our big thing.
And we're performing in
Germany at a music festival.
Our hope is to travel more
outside of the U.S. One
of our dreams has been to travel
back to our historic lands
and do one on one, you know,
archival collecting of songs,
to meet those people
that are still there
and are still singing those
songs however old they are
and if they can remember the words
we'll be all the more grateful
for it, and if they can
remember the melodies.
But that's been one of our dreams
for a long time is to be able
to continue to collect and
maybe save a few more songs
that haven't already been recorded.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian: Ara, what
are you dreaming about still doing?
>> Ara Dinkjian: My dreams have all
been fulfilled and then again some.
And if I have any more,
it would be to continue.
I have all these projects
in my mind.
I've done so many projects and been
so fortunate to have realized them,
and if I can continue and
do more at this point it's
for me the cherry on the cake.
I'm just grateful for whatever I've
been able to experience so far.
>> Anais Tekerian: I think we just
still have a lot more to express
in the same line of what we've been
doing, but it does evolve with time,
with who we become musically.
Things change.
Subtly maybe to other people's ears,
but we know how things
are changing for us.
And that's -- It's always exciting.
The more things start to
happen for us creatively,
the more things start to happen.
And that's a -- It's
a fun place to be in.
>> Ara Dinkjian: And you will go
to the historic lands and sing.
You will.
>> Teni Apelian: We believe a
lot in, you know, the muses,
and the things higher than
us that control our ability
to find songs and all
of those things.
So we just pray that they keep
giving us that ability really.
>> Carolyn Rapkievian:
Thank you very much.
Zulal and Ara Dinkjian were here
at the American Folk Life Center
of the Library of Congress.
It is May 28th and we've
enjoyed music and conversation.
Thank you again.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.